Unforeseen events, including the massive quake and tsunami in Japan...
...that triggered a man-made nuclear disaster,...
...and the political unrest that has roiled the Middle East and North Africa...
...are expected to loom large, as members of the World Bank and IMF gather in Washington.
Among the implications...
...is the rapid spike in oil prices and its potential to trigger another global economic slowdown.
Although the world economy is projected to grow at a moderate pace this year,...
...IMF Chief Dominique Strauss-Kahn says the recovery remains lopsided,...
...with China and other emerging economies growing faster than Western economies.
Ahead of the meeting, Portugal, one of the poorest countries in the Eurozone,...
...is now the third EU country to ask for a bailout to deal with its crippling debt.
Economists say other countries could follow.
The IMF is expected to stress the importance...
...of regulatory reforms to improve global financial stability...
...and narrow the gap between rich and poor.
Mil Arcega, VOA News.